camping à la ferme gîtes ruraux table
d'autres il ya là des solutions
accessibles avec un peu d'imagination à
tous ceux qui disposent d'un prêt d'eau
courante ou de quelques pièces aménagées
c'est une nécessité car un peu partout
en france des villages doivent trouver
des sources nouvelles de revenus sous
peine de mort des fermes qui ouvrent
leurs portes aux touristes
c'était la solution trouvée à partir des
années 1950 par quelques agriculteurs
pour diversifier leurs revenus
une pratique qui ne s'est jamais démodé
bien au contraire risque entre 1979 et
2010 la part des exploitations agricoles
qui propose des activités touristiques a
triplé passant de 1,1 à 3% pour certains
agriculteurs
l'accent est mis sur l'ouverture et la
rencontre de nouveaux horizons ça vous a
emballé de recevoir des contacts humains
mais pour la plupart des agriculteurs se
sont bien avant tout leurs difficultés
économiques qui les pousse à se
diversifier grâce à l'agritourisme
je suis agriculteur que mes voisins et
pour moi c'est une nécessité impérieuse
de trouver un appoint et c'est à point
c'est dans le tourisme que nous le
cherchons nous trouvons
au cours des années 1980 l'agritourisme
se développe avec la création de deux
réseaux nationaux accueil paysan et
bienvenue à la ferme
une structure qui regroupe aujourd'hui
plus de huit mille agriculteurs
adhérents et certains prennent vraiment
très à coeur leur rôle d'hôte
nous organisons des soirées
gastronomiques nous allons dans des
fermes auberges
nous avons des soirées les phares
automatiques quand vous faites tout ça
vous avez plus de temps de vous occuper
de votre ferr alors ça devienne un
problème c'est certain pour arriver à
s'occuper des vaches est puisque je
serriculteurs et je trait les vaches
matin et soir et alors les vaches matin
c'est certain je préfère m'occuper des
vaches en 2010 treize mille huit cents
exploitations pratiquer l'agritourisme
et certaines d'entre elles proposent des
prestations bien éloignée de la
rusticité des débuts les vacances à la
ferme évolué finie la simple toile de
tente sur leur exploitation laurent et
sa compagne sont ajoutés yourte gîte et
même cette tante bull pour une nuit tout
confort à la belle étoile
l'agritourisme marque donc aussi bien
ceux qui reçoivent que ceux qui visitent
la ferme
mais lorsqu'arrive le jour du départ ce
sont toujours les mêmes qui ont le plus
de mal à partir
pour qui pour vous pour pour eux pour
moi aussi parce que c'est vrai
[Musique]